[Music]
hey buff up up it's us thank you so much
heather for
putting up with us needing to reschedule
this since 2004. literally 2004.
it's fine i am so obsessed with you and
i it's very rare that someone gets like
really successful in this business
and everyone's happy for them
so congratulations on that thank you oh
my god you're happy for me i appreciate
it to have people like you and
for you that's so nice i it's good to
know that you are rooting for me because
like you never know you never know when
you see people out other comedians
you're like do they actually like me i
don't fucking know that's our first time
meeting and i i adore you so i feel like
this is great thank you i also have
watched a lot of your interviews and
stuff and something i love about you and
i want to work on is you
are
you don't self-deprecate in a way that
makes other people be like well wait
like
so like if you're not happy there's this
trend now where comedians all have to
talk about how miserable they are right
and how horrible their lives are and how
depressed they are and i feel like their
fans are like well like are you good we
like you
like didn't i just pay 80 to see you
live like didn't you just make a good
chunk of change in st louis last week
like what's your problem like you in the
interview stuff that you're like i'm
living my dream i'm so happy i've
reached my goals i have no complaints
like you're just like grateful and happy
i am a very joyful comic i will say that
you're not going yeah but i didn't get
this and it's like
the disease of no matter how successful
you get you're the compare and despair
of always looking at other people's uh
accomplishments or just
not enjoying it you just seem like
you're enjoying it and i just didn't for
the longest time i would say this though
i mean you don't want to ruin it for you
i know you really are today
yeah yeah yeah um they're like don't
have any joy or light behind i'm gonna
tell you all the reasons you shouldn't
be so hopeful yeah
as long as you're dead inside that means
you're doing you are happy and grateful
that stops today
um well it's funny i mean listen you
know i've just got over like my first
tour and like being on the road there
were moments where i was like this is
fucking gnarly brutal oh my god but i
feel like at the end of the day and i
really don't want to sound too
philosophical on here but i feel like
the end of the day i'm only competing
with myself because i know that my brand
of comedy i know that my brand of me my
audience like i just got to stay in my
lane that's like one thing i always
learn like coming up in anything but
like through business i'm like stay in
your lane i know i'm good at like doing
me like my shit yeah so like i can't
compare myself to somebody else we all
have different senses of humor point of
view perspective all this shit yeah and
the more specifically you are yourself
the less competition you do have because
there's no way to compete with something
that unique you know it is crazy like i
just had like one of the biggest moments
for me personally like in my career um
you got to meet me and it's look i it's
it's we're the same don't you don't you
show me your bathroom you already showed
me your acreage you're like i've got 130
acres suck my dick you live at home with
your mother you know what i mean every
time i have someone come over that i
like i show them what i have
and then uh later i will tell you what
it cost and it will lure you to come
live out here but see i appreciate that
because i'm i'm southern and that's a
southern thing like if you come to our
home i'm like let me show you what we
did upstairs with this with the the
runner like that's a very specific
southern ladybug i was talking to you i
was like we put the beams in she didn't
ask she didn't ask i was like and this
these arches we added these this used to
be a wet bar we changed it i'm just
giving you a tour you didn't ask for
right i actually want to jump into this
because
i'm a little bit like bipolar and that i
grew up in a very cosmopolitan area but
also very southern as well and when i
was listening on something i was like oh
there's so few southern comedians at
least that i get to see a lot i don't
mean the blue collar guys or whatever
but it's just so fun to me i want to go
through a couple things things that you
do not find in the north that you only
find in the south sometimes a different
sense of humor a different pace but
there are some customs that are
different that i really
miss like i'm secretly a really
traditional
um uh like i'll show you my teacups
after this
i'm very serious about my teacups and my
coasters
manners and like you you know you have
pimento cheese you always have a spread
you're always going to have a spread i
don't give a fuck of it you show up to
my house at 3am you will have a cool
beverage and you'll have some sort of
snack to regulate your blood sugar that
you will have limeade you will have if
you come to my home absolutely okay
there will be a sweet tea and an unsweet
tea absolutely okay there will be
pimento cheese there are no palmer's
there will be crackers that hurt the
roof of your mouth yeah they're so
crusty and fancy
have you ever had saltines that they
bake them in butter so you take a sheet
of saltines you just put butter all over
it a little bit of like old bay
seasoning and then you bake it at our
country club they serve those in atlanta
literally and it's like no bread service
it's just salty buttery crackers okay so
things in the southern customs okay that
you do not find in the north yeah
monogram pillows
okay now here's the thing this is a very
controversial subject i have you'll see
i came in with my luggage today is a
luggage monogram you betcha
but is this a southern thing or sorority
thing it's both and i did both so you
have to i know where you have to put
letters on everything you do have to put
letters on everything i like it though i
think it's nice so that way if anybody's
ever trying to snatch my bag in the
airport i go hands off sir i would just
go i'm not gonna fuck with the bitch
that goes out of her way to get her
luggage monogrammed my bed pillows are
monogrammed yes
too and they're not they don't have my
husband's monogram on him because if you
want to go real southern it's just
because i'm not taking his last name
it's just my name so art we have these
really expensive fucking sheets and it's
just my name monogram sheets so it's
like the whole point of making it bad is
like it's hard enough if you have
monograms then you have to make it good
it's just you can see it's just the hero
shams that's all i have i don't have
like sheets that say like this is
heather's bed get the fuck out
she knows that aps home is where the
heart is yes yes
gather you know
the four seasons in beverly hills they
monogram every single person i love that
cheat and it's so great
but what is it you go you see you you go
to lie down and you're like yep it's
mine yes 100 and then somebody this
really cool company um in north carolina
they sent me stuff so my dog's name is
rigatoni so they sent me monogrammed
stuff with like rigatoni's butler
riggatoni's mom right tony's dad and
they're like really gorgeous sheets and
i uh like jeffy lay on rigatoni's dad
that pillow and it's just very small
it's very subtle yes those are like the
light little touches it feels like a
a prideful family tradition and i like
that i like that and my dad right before
he died he looked at me and he's like i
love your you know at the time boyfriend
but he's like i love jeff but you will
not take his last name and i said aye
captain what was his life what is his
last name sorry what as if you just
deleted it from jeff's last name is
daniels so i should be heather daniels
which is a beautiful name but he was
like you're a mcmahon and then he just
saluted me
took his last breath and i was like you
got it dad yeah he's like you're just a
mcmahon i said that's fine have you guys
ever talked about merging your last
names what would it be so we talked
about that but jeff is man it'd be dan
mann would be mcdaniels we could do
mcdaniels or you could do
dan man dan man yeah
we could do damn man man
the damn man jeff has said he's like all
i want is i never want he's like fine
our kids will be daniel's that's fine
he's like i just don't ever want to see
on the back of like a soccer uniform it
says mcmahon daniels that bullshit that
no dude pick one yep yep yep no dashes
no asterix yeah
yeah alex uh my dude when we talk about
marriage we talk about merging our name
but his last name is barnes and mine is
cummings so it'll be cumbern
that's terrible okay do you call it a
toilet or a commode i do not call it a
commode but i will say i do say ladies
room i don't say where's the bathroom i
say can you point me in the direction of
the ladies room you have about another
six months in california
before you just get shot in the head
you just get shot
i did not even think about that you're
right i cannot say but if can i say
ladies room if i identify as a daddy you
can
i'm there's certain traditional things
that i'm not giving up yeah that are not
out of any spite but like yes sir yes
ma'am if i did not say yes sir yes ma'am
i got smacked upside the head absolutely
you know so i still do it i'll go yes
ma'am yes sir and oftentimes i'm just
not looking and i'll say yes sir and
look up and it's a tsa i'm like yeah
ma'am sorry no i think
um sane people know you're just trying
to be polite but it's weird i've gotten
in a couple like unnecessary skirmishes
because i'm like yes ma'am and i was
like mom am i that old and i'm like
don't shame me
because
you know i was being polite i was on set
in atlanta we were shooting this movie
and if i want to call you old
yeah i'd do that
like you out of the way grandma yeah
exactly
like i didn't think you were old until
you did this old ass bit yeah i now have
to feel bad for being polite i was on
set and we had a female director and was
phenomenal and one of the the lighting
guys said yes ma'am to her and she lost
her fucking shit and i had to pull her
aside and go hey we're in georgia this
man is not being rude she's like he's
dressing me down i was like no no he's
literally being like saying like you got
it captain you got it yeah he's
literally just saying i i hear you i
respect you you got it yes and then i'm
like and i'm the only one based out of
atlanta there and i'm just like these la
fucks who were just
by everything and
he's just a nice 65 year old lighting
guy who wants to make sure that you feel
like he heard you yes and by the way
this whole thing of like chivalry is not
uh you know modern for having a man do
things for you that as a boss that's
what you have to do you have to accept
help you're going like
you're not you have a choice in the
matter right you don't allow yourself to
be
treated well
yeah i'm never gonna be like i'm in my
own door i'm an independent woman i work
my ass off i do my shit but if you don't
think that i want jeff to like lay that
dick down and maybe make me a snack
after
chivalry is not dead you know what i
mean i do miss cabbage with a sword
um jeff okay hold on you know those
shit uh like those little mini fridges
that you get sent for like skin care
yeah i got one of those sent to me my
husband swear to god was like oh i like
this mini fridge she's like so what do
we do with this and i'm like
you know i put my eye creams he
literally thought it was for like next
to the bed that i would put like cold
cuts or like you know some peanut butter
or some boiled eggs yeah he just thought
it was for after sex he had a little
mini fridge to pull out like a slim gym
i'm like no motherfucker it's for my
expensive skin care i like because
they're always like pink or like rose
gold daddy's like oh this is the sexy
fridge yeah and he thought he was just
gonna have like loose cold cuts just
like strawberries covered in chocolate
they're never big enough to hold more
than eye cream so i don't understand i
got one and it didn't get cold enough i
agree and it was just like it it felt
very like i feel like
a child's fingers were lost in the
making of this 100 percent you know what
i mean somewhere in cambodia and you're
like i don't want to support this yeah
um okay so there's something else that
uh that i noticed in the difference in
south and north that is like a thing
that's very hard to pinpoint i'm
obsessed with the biological basis of
customs and traditions where if you are
saying bye to someone in the north it's
like going to say i love you and you
walk away right south it's like a
30-minute but there's a 30-minute
draw out
oh okay i hear what you're saying
goodbyes are long you're saying like you
linger too long you linger
you get up from the restaurant you stand
in the parking lot you got to look at
the car
i never thought about that and you're
absolutely right there is no like chill
later go fuck yourself and say well
we're going to stand outside this
applebee's really work work it out
we just left spinnakers and now i need
to look at the new car
this is the new car because this this we
painted this car this new paint yeah
this is lincoln we just really gave
kaley to go off to college with that's
right and you know what it actually came
back in one piece and we're surprised
okay so and then it turns out and where
is she in college again oh she's at
alabama oh yeah
you're all tired
um and so you gotta and then it's like
you're in the parking lot didn't there
used to be was it
wasn't that
what was that a taco bell no that no no
it was a hardy's remember it was a
hearties and that they had a salmonella
outbreak over there what was it before
the hardee's was it checkers burger uh
it was checkers burgers
they also had a salmonella outbreak so
have you seen where the new taco bell
the new taco bell down the street over
uh by the belt yeah oh we fucking love a
belt and a dillards
fuck with that
it's like we and that's like the weather
when i'm in virginia we all and i'm like
i am obsessed i can't stand small talk
like it makes me angry
and i i feel like people are stealing my
life because my thing is like we don't
we don't have to do this like you don't
have to we don't have to do this like
right we can either i go straight to big
talk like what meds are you on how they
mixing i gotcha
or or let's just not talk at all we can
sit in silence you know and that is what
is inherently southern about me i
absolutely cannot sit in silence and i'm
sure that a therapist one day will
dissect this but literally one of my my
one of my best friends christina she's
on the road with me she's like you have
no ability just to not you have to talk
like like if i'm meeting somebody
backstage or one of those shows i get
their whole life story i'm now you know
that's also why you're interesting a
great comic you're curious but i'm i'm
the worst version of that which is like
if i'm driving in the car with someone
yeah i'll just read the signs and read
the restaurant names i'll be like lucky
now uh-huh oh just like talking to
yourself about that no see i'm in the
car and i'm like let's spill back the
layers what happened yesterday when you
had a slight meltdown because they put
swiss on your sandwich instead of prove
alone like i'm actually always trying to
figure it out and fix it's okay so so
when we sit down to uh dinner at 2 p.m
yeah uh yeah in virginia um
it's the weather we're talking about the
weather the weather it's been crazy it's
raining yeah it's been raining i mean we
had okay yeah we thought we were gonna
have them on soon we can't actually have
those in virginia but we thought but it
has been 94 every day this year and then
as soon as you've covered all the
weather of this year and there's nothing
else
this time last year i remember wearing a
windbreaker i think this time last year
was just windier
goddamn it was winter it was windier
that's a good observation it was windy
as hell i it was just so windy mm-hmm i
remember i had to change the shutters
around was that last year the year
before no that was 2005. that was
actually a long time are you sure yeah
i'm sure i'm sure that's lacy's
graduation yeah it was lacey's
graduation
and we when we lost the okra we
blew right off the table okay
okay
i also want a preface i'm from atlanta
okay i went to school in mississippi so
even that was culture shock for me like
when i showed up at ole miss i was like
the where the fuck am i but i'm also
from like a big city you know if you're
fighting metropolis in atlanta do i have
a couple you know sisters and cousins
who are absolutely and everyone has a
double name it's like swelling sarah
kate mara beth caroline i have that in
my life but i am also like in atlanta
proper yeah yeah yeah which is just like
a modern city which is just
we had the olympics you know you know
what
we did a shitty job and i did host the
olympics of 96. i'm like but when you
are out hunting for food every day you
can read can't you
yeah yeah um something i do want to
discuss uh you have a wedding coming up
your own wedding my own wedding and i
would like to make an announcement to
everyone attending weddings attending
your wedding
in general um i
i i the my problem i have with weddings
is that
everyone i can't wait for this the
problem with weddings you won't know
about this because you're going to be
the bride and they'll spare you this but
you'll every time you go to a wedding
especially that's a destination wedding
okay all the guests want to do is talk
about
how you got there yeah what you flew
how you flew
what
airport you landed in on do you take the
train the logistics is a for for sure
conversation in the world you just get
in i'm just i'm in italy i've got my
sarong on i'm playing
i'm in italy i'm like going down these
cobblestone steps italy oh my god hey
gina and it's like just starts with did
y'all just get in yeah
yeah
where'd you flying into what flight what
flight were you on you know what i love
too about southerners with the travel
they will always carry you always know
you're in the south or do you have a
southerner i know that i'm going to have
relatives they're going to show up with
all their clothes not in a hanging bag
but just all these fun hangers do you
know what i mean it is such a specific
thing if you're ever checking into them
and you just see a bunch of you always
know they're from especially virginia i
was doing a show in richmond and sure
enough everybody check into the hotel
just had their their clothes on hangers
not in a bag not in a roll away just you
know come on coral grab grab my dresses
and they just bring them in their
hangers from home and high heeled
espadrilles toes over the front all
gripping
and then it's but it never ends like i
was actually when i went to a wedding in
italy it started to be like the game for
me of the weekend of how long is someone
going to talk to you about about the
travel itinerary so it's it's first you
get in okay so yeah you just got in yeah
i just got in today yeah yeah where'd
you where'd you fly in oh directly to
florence but we had to connect through
charles de gaulle oh yeah wait so you
went through charles de gaulle from yeah
atlanta through it from atlanta paris
paris paris here at a two hour two and a
half same airline for both you had to
actually hit a switch yeah yeah when air
france
i saw that i did see that flight but i
did i we we decided we were gonna go
long beach uh germany it was just then
down here
but let me ask you what did you then
from the airport was it uh did you take
the tram no i didn't i didn't have to
take the tram or
we got a taxi because you know my
husband speaks decent italian yeah so i
we were able to navigate oh but okay so
you got oh so you got cash when you got
it no so this one actually took credit
cards i'll tell you what i've been
searching for an atm for 45 minutes
because you know nobody else takes care
takes credit cards it's bullshit right
right so um cool yeah yeah yeah yeah so
when you head back um actually tomorrow
the first thing as soon as you get there
all right what does is ask about what
when you when you head back you go on
sunday we're actually not even attending
the wedding
we came we said hi and then i gotta get
back because i have a colonoscopy
thursday i know i have to go tell
someone else about my travel plans be
right back because then and there's
always someone at the wedding that wants
you to ride back with them always always
do you want to share something do you
want okay let's get out when are you
going back when are you going back
tomorrow
me too what flight uh 1505 it's at the
1pm that's what that's the one where
okay so what are why don't we go
together to the airport um well we get
there we get there very early
to the bride and groom right now they're
trying to toast we're trying to figure
are you cool to leave at 9 a.m the
flight's at four but are you cool to
leave at night
yeah let me i mean i have four babies
with me so i will just have to wrangle
them i'll take a baby yeah i can i'm not
i'm also gluten free so oh no
you could just provide some gluten-free
snack options and then you're changing
your flight you're spending the entire
weekend trying to fly back with uncle
jeb
can i tell you too with the just the
gluten-free moment
i put something on my like my wedding
invitation like obviously let us know if
you have a dietary restriction like if
you're allergic shellfish just fucking
let me know but i'm honestly i'm not
going to honor any of that like i
actually got some shit in and i was like
you're gluten-free don't fucking come to
italy you're allergic to tomatoes yeah
don't come bring a couple fucking kind
bars put them in your purse
to be fed at a wedding it is not your
job it's not about food for you i had
somebody literally respond i don't like
not an allergy i don't like onions or
mushrooms and i literally responded it
was their date it was their plus one and
i go just don't come lol and everyone
thinks that i'm kidding but i was like
no literally go find yourself who does
that
it's there's a lot of wedding faux pas
that i feel very strongly about um uh
i didn't realize what would actually
bother me until like so far well just
like that like the fucking bullshit
about the food also let me ask you
something did you say
let me know if you have allergies i said
just if you have allergies not if you
don't like if you're gonna die if you're
gonna go into anaphylactic shock let us
know yeah like one of my best friends
she's got fucking peanut allergy i know
to let the caterer know this bitch is
going down this isn't about preference
it's whether you're going to die or not
it's like
does not like onions or mushrooms do we
need an epipen
that's the question thank you i will all
dave
well i when i went to a friend of mine's
wedding in italy there was a rule you
cannot bring a guy or girl unless you've
been together at least a year met the
parents and said i love you because i
like that like random plus ones can
really
and i am such a people pleaser that i
have decided everybody gets a plus one i
do have a group of girlfriends who i'm
like there's 15 of my like sorority
sisters i'm like y'all are just gonna
travel together and then y'all and mary
just come together but there are um oh
the plus ones has become a whole fucking
thing and on top of that i have had
people who have asked me how do we get
there i'm like you have the wedding
website
they're like but do i connect through
here and i'm like google this shit
motherfucker why are you asking me seven
days out if you haven't booked your
flight you're fucked how are you at
escape rooms every weekend but you can't
fucking figure out how to get to italy
like it drives me insane i i've started
doing it and the people that matter
don't mind and the people that mine that
don't matter where i will write back i'm
not trying to be bitchy
i just will write back because this is
something you could find on google and i
will say please don't ask me any
questions if you go on google and it's
still confusing let me know because
everyone's going to be confused yeah but
it is still to this day
the person that beg every time i see
them i want to come see you live i want
to see you live did you go on oh by the
way i'll be fine whether you come or not
but now when someone's like i want to
see you live i'm like cool just let me
know anytime text me okay and then the
next time you see them hey i've just
been so crazy busy i'm like i'm fine man
now you're making me deal with and then
finally like great i'll come see the
this weekend whatever
hey how where do i park i'm getting all
these texts i'm like what is going on in
your brain when you think i should be
personally
assisting you it's 15 fucking minutes
before i step on stage and i will get
dms texts whatever where's parking what
do you mean cheryl i don't even know
where parking is i parked in a car that
dropped me off at the stage door i don't
know
in between
dumpsters like
the back of two
it makes me like um
i i have to be honest with you i've
called out a lot of people and when
people text asking for tickets and stuff
i either just won't respond or like my
thing is you kind of have to just get
tickets even if we're friends because i
know you're gonna
when you go get a ticket to see pink i
know you don't get confused about where
to park right
if you go
like i just mean like if you go through
the regular channels i think you'll
treat it more like a serious thing
instead of like you're just hanging with
your friend
i learned that the hard way because i
just did like i closed out my tour at
the fox theater in atlanta and this was
like such an iconic moment for me i was
like this is my dream as a kid to play
the fox right incredible two shows of
the box was so much fun and i had a
little after party afterwards and that
was the biggest mistake of my life
because literally you know and am i one
of my dearest friends at ages she was
like just so you know it's a hometown
shows that you're going to be most
disappointed in because the people that
you know the the best they're going to
be the ones who try and take 25 miles
you know what i mean they're going to be
balanced like can i bring 65 friends to
this after party i'm like no the
entitlement the entitlement but here's
the thing it's one thing to do it but go
hey
i would like to bring a bunch of people
i know they're people you're going to
want to see who can i talk to at the
venue yeah to advance that
yes no no it's because there's no way
it's also it's so funny i was talking to
marilyn ricegum about this um the other
day we uh uh she came with me to um do a
show in vancouver we were performing
together in toronto and we were talking
about i was like you know doing a tv
show while about to shoot my special
right and i was like god this is like
stand-up is a full-time job and she goes
yeah it's my favorite thing when i come
off stage after doing an hour of
stand-up and people like so like what
are you working on
you're like what like what do you know
but like what are you doing like what
are you up to these days you're like
that what i just did
what i just did but two breaths ago
you're like i could never do that
and now you're like so what are you
actually doing
i will say i have learned so much about
myself being on the road i have learned
about the world being on the road i've
learned about my family being on there
like i've just learned
now that i did it i did 94 shows like i
fucking did awesome check it off i'm
like i did it for myself right had the
time of my life but i have just like
grown exponentially as a human as a
woman as a business person being on the
road and doing that shit but you can't i
mean all the things that we're wired for
for whatever reasons nature nurture
social construction right the people
pleasing all that shit you have to be so
direct if you're going to be touring
like that and it really helped me you
know overcome
worrying people would think i'm a bitch
because you've got to say this needs to
happen and then like when you're doing
your soundcheck this needs to happen
this needs to happen like the nicest
thing you can do is be super direct and
go
and not be like whatever you think
whatever you think there's no time no no
i'm straight and you're too tired and
you and it you have to advocate for
yourself constantly on the road and just
make sure you have everything you need
whereas i'm like hey i need to lay down
for an hour i can't have anyone knock on
my door yeah which like was would have
been very hard for me to say 10 years
ago but now i like i being on the road
has just made me kind of the person i
have wanted to be for so long because i
just had to be that i'm always surprised
and i think my audiences had to learn a
little bit but or like you know like i
have other friends that come out to the
show like hey meet us at the bar across
the street we'll buy you some drinks
before the show i go i don't know how to
tell you this i'm putting on a fucking
90-minute show
this is my job you're showing up to work
if you worked at t-mobile i wouldn't be
like you want 75 margaritas before your
shit
or actually maybe i would but i'm like
no i'm not going drinking with you
before my show we had a i never by the
way i never have guested shows only if
it's like hardcore family someone that
want a thing someone that's sick or you
know something like that or something
like truly someone who's sick okay but
like
aren't we doing a proposal with someone
like if someone wants to propose to that
person like ten proposals and i realized
i enjoy that though because my love that
is like i'm very into being a part of
people's lives
which um a lot of people who don't want
me a part of their lives but um i i yeah
i love a proposal how were you proposed
to
oh okay
so we go to the turks and caicos a lot
that's our jam so pretty yeah it's so
pretty um so we have a place down there
you really live your life i get out i
travel i love that i do yeah hey y'all
taking a break a manic break that is
god i'm overwhelmed
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
i'm burned out and i do know it me i
knew that
that's why i like better help not only
do we love better help but nova kaplan
my makeup artist we secretly were
filming her yesterday talking about how
incredible better help has been for her
she loves her better health therapist
and let's roll that now being depressed
is the new being pretty
betterhelp.com
that's i use it because of you i
literally do i love my therapist like i
didn't like my first one it's not that
he was bad he just wasn't for me yeah
yeah and it was but you can switch at
any time and then i
i found the my second person like i just
they're perfect yeah and you can text
them any time
it's not a crisis line
and it's not self-help
no you're reading this no she's reading
the copy
from the teleprompter in her mind we're
just knocking out some ads yeah right
now therapy is a game changer there's no
excuse to be crazy anymore
stop crying in your car
stop eating cake if you have your car
out of your purse
no more purse cake
well i mean look it's hard to tell these
days what is a cake and what is it so
true
honestly
one thing i know that is not a cake i'm
90 sure these better help counselors are
not okay true
but it is a cake walk to get on better
help because online therapy helps you
prioritize yourself talking with someone
can help you reduce stress in your life
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so i
guess it's a piece of cake
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours our
listeners get ten percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com whitney
that's betterhelp.com
whitney and a couple of you that leave
youtube comments about my face
this one's for you this one's for you
yesterday said who's that old blonde
woman sitting next to whitney it's chris
it's chris evans
my new boyfriend it's good for you it's
confirmed good for you listener chris
evans
your new boyfriend is trying to keep
your self esteem low so that you don't
leave him for christmas he's necking me
earnestly guys
speaking of your boyfriend student loans
ernest is my boyfriend's name
speaking of emily and my boyfriend
student loans
uh how do you
how do you feel when you think about
your student loans i don't have any
because i paid mine uh because i live in
fear of debt but
i'm dumb and i'm dating someone that
just got out of medical school and he's
riddled with debt and loans and it's a
nightmare yeah and especially since we
talk about it all the time uh with him
he's overwhelmed he's stressed he's
anxious and we don't talk about it i
taunt him right that's different well
ernest wants to help him out because
ernest was the number one student loan
refinance company in 2021 according to
financial you know where number two was
competitors
goofball can you tell everyone quickly
what you wanted to name your production
company donkey punch
and then my business manager went you
know that when you die your children
will get your checks and it'll say
donkey punch
ernest has helped over 200 000 borrowers
refinance over 18 billion dollars of
student loans that's like so much money
what bezos makes that's like i want to
say like 18
billion
dollars absolutely refinancing could
help you pay off your loan faster save
money or combine multiple loans into one
monthly payment take two minutes to see
what your new rate could be and lock in
a low rate before the next rate hike if
you refinance right now ernest is
offering our listeners a 100 dollar cash
bonus i could i'll take that refinance
or student debt at earnest.com whitney
not available in all states
once again you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com whitney
to refinance your student loan visit
earnest.com whitney for more details not
available in all states terms and
conditions apply
earnest student loan refinancing and i'm
going to hand it over to whitney because
this is the heartbreak made by earnest
operations llc nmls number sign
120
4917 california financing law license
number
605-4788-535 mission street san
francisco california
94105 visit earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses i
have a couple um yuck yuck shows to
promote i'm still doing the yuck yuck
still trying to get my dad dad to love
me so on june 24th i'm gonna be in
calgary alberta uh prince island park
i'm gonna be with david spade
david spade donnell rawlings and myself
june 26th i'm going to be in toronto
ontario at the danforth music hall um
july 1st the hamptons i'm going to be in
west hampton beach new york that's going
to be a wild one emily and i will be
hiding in your suitcases getting lyme
disease
september 8th four days after my
birthday i'm going to celebrate by going
to cincinnati
ohio at the taft theater september 9th
i'll be in philadelphia pennsylvania
miriam theater went to college in
philadelphia so all my exes come through
september 10th richmond virginia i'll be
at the national i'm emily's going to
bring up that you went to college there
so go for it all my exes come through
september
all my ex come through
you come sir
uh september 24th i'll be in
charlottesville virginia the hornets
charlotte hornets right no that's north
we've been through this that's north
carolina we've been through this don't
embarrass me in front of my fans
charlotte's bill grace's fan it's called
yes and this is why you're not an improv
star charlottesville is the cavaliers uh
september 24th charlottesville virginia
i'll be at the paramount theater i'm
very excited for that now let's get back
to more gobbledygook
do you think okay i i want to hear about
the proposal but i also wanted to start
with this but now what do you think
there is a difference
between people as i get older i'm
starting to put people in categories
that help me make shortcuts
people that play team sports
okay people that were only child uh-huh
people that were in sororities or
fraternities
and like like they're a different type
of person right like everyone i know
that was in a sorority fraternity they
do trips they trap they can coordinate a
road trip they're doing a wine country
trip like there's a concept of i like
having
living my life to the fullest
so
i was in a sorority and which one which
one i was a delta gamma at the
university of mississippi and honestly
anchor up sisters i had a fucking great
time and what were you emily delta delta
delta oh try down can i help you help
you you where were your tried out
university of richmond oh fantastic i
hear they're a great chapter good for
you okay so sororities always have some
like they have a character what would i
be if i was in a story which one well
it's very specific from school to school
uh she you know at my school she'd be a
theta our kappas were very southern like
oh no they're capitals were cool dg's
and kappa is to be an
no it's not it's actually nice whitney
it's not you know what you'd really be
you wouldn't even be a fucking single
guy you'd be the house mom at sigma guy
and that my friend yeah yeah i mean so i
started getting mom rolls even earlier
yeah sigma is a fraternity that's right
[Laughter]
honestly if i if things go south with my
husband if i ever have to like retire
off the road i've said i would go back
and be a house mom and a fraternity and
a fucking heartbeat
that would be my dream because my whole
life people have said like you kind of
remind me of stiffler's mom because even
when i was 18 they were like you kind of
look like older jennifer coolidge so i
would just like like everyone's thought
i was 57 when i was that one yeah i mean
the same same well it's because we have
like new
voices
yeah and we have a level of confidence
that is didn't make any sense when we
were younger without a doubt like it
just like delusional confidence
delusional to the point where people
were like are you is your child okay
i'm now a shell of a person but when i
was young
i mean but also i think that being in
the south does help but you know people
are always like how are you so confident
how do you go on stage like i have a lot
of answers for it um but one of them is
like my uh in the south my aunt's you
had to like we would go to a nursing
home to visit like a family friend yeah
every saturday you would get the you
know pimento cheese you'd wrap up a loaf
you'd get a zucchini bread you'd make
all this food all morning and then you
would go to the nursing home and visit
with someone yeah and do the their
laundry and whatever just like a family
friend and then my aunt would push me
into rooms of just random people and be
like entertain joey talk to this person
about the war yes
the great war i literally would just be
like hi sir i just wanted to say hi and
i would introduce myself to these like
deaf people that were like hanging out
and you you know
there was i was put in so many social
situations where i had like i grew up on
a golf course right okay and does golf
really stand for gentlemen only ladies
forbidden i thought it did but
apparently it doesn't but i still think
that there is we are denying we go in
the world of female golf and we could
talk about it on a whole nother episode
do women want to golf yeah badly yes i
played golf in high school i love golf
it's actually a fucking blast and i say
golf and stand up are very similar okay
because
i played team sports and i played solo
sports i played you know soccer and all
that bullshit growing up but then golf i
took it serious but golf is very similar
to stand-up because you only have
yourself to blame right but you will be
like but you will blame every fucking
other element it was too hot the wind i
got stuck in the bunker
and stand up you're like the audience
they were too drunk the lighting i
didn't like the energy of the theater
you know what i mean to me golf and and
stand up are so similar i just feel like
yes i i i like a i would rather a mental
sport than a physical sport yeah um golf
seems to me unnecessarily hard
like we have upgrades in the area of
sports entertainment i would just be
like i down like it's like i just it's a
whole bit about ballet it's like we
don't need to do that anymore you know
what i mean like there's certain things
they're like i just feel like we could
make the golf holes like twice as big
like because we have to have them played
golf whitney this is actually highly
offensive to all of the athletes out
there that have spent their entire lives
trying to play the hardest game in the
world now that we have half as much time
as humans maybe we should have twice as
big a hole in golf
it's called evolution hey to everybody
on the lpga
so the
lgbtqga what i'll join that one that
sounds funny
i am into it it just seemed i don't want
to play a sport where i also have to be
a meteorologist
yeah
i don't do tennis i don't know the ace
love deuce
you know i don't get it i don't at 15
you got to win five sets of the six
matches it doesn't make sense it seems
to me like doing the same thing over and
over again expecting a different result
so the definition of insanity you don't
get to you enjoy it for two like when i
play volleyball basketball you get to do
something and you need to enjoy it for a
second the second you hit the ball to
tennis you already got to be panicked
right like you don't have a minute to
enjoy anything good the golf is leisure
i think it's good on the cortisol your
adrenals shouldn't be up yeah yeah i
mean you can play it leisurely you can
play competitively i quit playing
competitively because my dad because i
was like the son my dad never had so i
was at my like championship game and um
i could hear i banned my dad from coming
to the matches and i could hear him
opening a diet coke can in the bushes
like i literally heard that
island or something and he was like god
damn it i mean my dad was a very large
heavyset southern man and i was like no
dad no you can't be here anymore so then
i quit playing competitive and my golf
coach pulled me aside in high school and
i very thankfully did this he pulled my
dad aside he goes i don't know how to
tell you this but she's got big boobs
now and it completely changes your swing
so i had to rework my swing and then it
just got i was like you know when i'm
out i'm out i was like
help you is me and if i just go behind
her
i go behind her and help her yeah hold
her boobs down while she yeah yeah i
wish i there's so many people i know
that get so much out of golf and it has
improved their life dramatically um in a
lot of ways it's a thing you can do
forever and i'm listening i'm not here
to fucking convince you or your
listeners that you everybody should
start playing golf i just enjoy it and
so but it is one of those games where it
is so hard to be good yeah so i just
like i know i'm never going to be great
at it yeah yeah i'm good i'm decent but
then it's just like it's you know it's
you know what's really fun about like i
went when my uh she's turning a corner
you know
should kill themselves but you know
what's good about golf go to the masters
i will say this go have that experience
i think you should i want to go to the
saint andrews one so i'm trying to go
that was supposed to be my big surprise
for my husband on our honeymoon because
on the tail end of our honeymoon how did
he propose okay so he proposed in a pool
actually in a pool of blood a pool of
blood
yes so we were down in the turks and my
husband's very sentimental and very
sweet so this place he's from where he's
from new york oh nice yeah yeah so he's
the italian styling from new york so
we're at our favorite place called
waimara and turks and caicos and it's
this really special place my dad helped
develop the property and like we would
go down there forever so one of my fav
one of my favorite photos i lost my dad
to cancer a couple years ago so one of
my favorite photos is this photo of my
dad and i in this pool at happy hour
having a margarita jeff's in the photo
my mom my sister like just like it
reminds me of like a pinnacle happy
point in my life right a core memory so
we're in the pool it's five o'clock and
i had a feeling he was gonna do it this
one weekend because i also threatened
him with his life i'm like we've been
together ten years if you don't like
i'll kill you but hey you've talked
about it oh a million times i it's a
foregone conclusion but now you're just
that to me is what's annoying is when
you know it's going to happen and now
i'm just like i'm this um
i'm the every time you lean you know
kneel down the tiger shoe
oh like now i'm waiting every time every
time we pass a fountain i'm like
adjusting thinking it's hanging on yeah
i
shut down with surprises okay as
somebody i think because i'm an
entertainer i like to control the
narrative i love like i'm like the
christian wig character on snl if i'm
doing a baby shower
i
love throwing surprises because i think
that
when we're not in control there's a
chance we could get embarrassed oh
that's a good point about that yeah i
just also i i so i shut down i was like
listen if you ever do this do not
fucking do it like on a jumbotron don't
do it in a public space i have a theory
about that guys that want to do uh a
proposal on jumbotron don't really love
the woman well yeah
no but it's like this is the closest you
can get to being on a jumbotron in a
sports game yes you'll never
yeah
um so
he so i could feel the energy though
because all of a sudden i saw the cabana
boys going around like asking all the
other patrons of this resort to get out
of the pool and like it happened in slow
motion to the point where i kind of like
stroked out for a minute i like turn the
corner and as i turn the corner to look
towards like the ocean i saw a
photographer in the corner literally
also hanging out by a bush and then i
saw our one of our shitty is that guy at
his job
why didn't he look but i'm hyper
observant you know as a comedian yeah
i'm on god something's happening and i'm
literally like i could feel it on the
back of my neck i could feel the energy
the shift i saw the other i saw my new
vacation friends getting out and they're
like oh my god it's happening you're
gonna be able to feel it i can feel it
so jeff had made this really beautiful
um he's very crafty made this beautiful
float out of flowers and it's sort of
floating towards us and everybody's
getting out of the pool and i'm like
it's happening it's happening like i'm
sweating i'm just melting and um he had
the ring we had a box in the middle of
this flower float and i thought he was
pulling the ring out of the flower but
there was a
a little thing that was significant
about it and he didn't pull the ring out
of there he pulled the ring so he opens
his box there's no ring in it he pulls
the ring out of his
fucking swim trunks
out of a box opens it water's gushing
out and he's like you know don't make
another man the happiest man in the
world will you marry me and i go you had
that in your fucking pocket in the pool
he was afraid he was getting lost i
guess or he's just men are dumb
and then i i do from what i understand i
love hearing guys talk about proposing
because they're basically turned into um
like james bond they've got a jewel
they're jewels the heisters they have to
hide it they have to put in their rocket
they have to like he hid it in our hotel
room the whole time and i had no idea he
like put it in a vase but like everybody
like we're obviously very close to
people down at this resort like
everybody knew like the manager helped
them build this thing in the office
although there's a lot of lying that has
to go on it is weird because i know so
many people that their their uh husband
or wife or whatever lied to them so much
in order to make the proposal romantic
it feels like this isn't going to work
out it was like this is the most
beautiful thing you've ever done but
you've been lying to me for a year right
like now i can't trust you
he opened the box and i didn't even say
yes i go
i literally yelled i'm a falcon's wife
because the only thing i said was we've
been together since we were young and i
was like the only thing i want is i want
to feel like i'm an nfl wife that's like
i'm a falcons one
and then he was like what i was like yes
i said yes but and then i pushed him out
of all of the photos and it was just a
solo photo shoot of me in the pool with
a glass of champagne and and then of
course afterwards we got the pool and
i'm like oh my god this is so crazy
we're taking photos and i'm like so
where are we going to dinner he's like i
don't know
what do you mean
as far as i got yeah yeah yeah so with
my husband i'm not pushing it he can do
one thing but if you expect him to plan
a day that will not happen he's like i
surprised you i booked you a massage but
nothing after that i had a girlfriend
one of my best friends her husband so
thoughtful
so thoughtful yeah but it was like i had
to execute like a scavenger hunt it was
like it's like i think sometimes guys
try so hard to make it thoughtful that
it just ends up being so drawn out that
all my eggs are going to be dead by the
time 100 like i'd rather eggs are dead
for sure but yeah can you do it sooner
just like at cracker barrel like that
would be you know i'm trying to think
there's another one that i love a friend
of mine uh her husband proposed her this
was like 10 years ago right after she
got out of the shower and she's like god
why would you do that he goes and he got
down on one knee and was like i just
you're the woman i love like with
nothing else like this is you at your
most i love you and you're wrong
that's what it was it was like i just i
love you for you here and she's like i
don't get the fuck out of here like i
don't you i don't have to accept myself
with no makeup on if you do that's fine
but i'm gonna go put some fucking makeup
on because we're gonna facetime all of
our friends i was pissed because we took
all these photos i mean i've spent the
whole day at the beach i got sand i'm
windswept i had like you know the zinc
oxide like chapstick ring on my mouth i
didn't have any makeup on her she's like
i mean when i look back it's obviously
very funny and great and he did get me
because i knew he was going to do it on
that trip but i didn't think it'd be in
the fucking pool also there was
also there's something that was uh uh a
guy friend of mine uh was proposing to
his girlfriend and he told her to get a
manicure
before the trip
obviously but he was like well don't you
want to get a manager to like look nice
and she had no idea what was going on
and she was like uh i think he's like a
psychopathic like possessive superficial
asshole because the family was going to
be on the trip and it was like can you
get a manicure before you meet my family
is how it came off but how did she not
pick up on that i'm sorry i am so sorry
she must be deaf-blind and dumb it was a
little bit soon it was like a year in
they were meeting the parents it was
like three weeks in and he's just serial
killer
he needed citizenship pronto you're
gonna cut your fingers off he needs to
be manicured
and then i have one friend who i really
want to make this uh movie he
uh was going on a family reunion trip uh
with his uh fiance and it was like a
cruise to alaska it's 80 of his family
members and then like some other people
that are in this cruise to alaska it's
for seven days he's like i'm gonna go to
this family reunion and i'm gonna
propose and i was like
great i just
advise you do it on the last day of the
trip yeah i would just wait till the
last day yeah day one they get in a
fight
and it's like where is this fucking
going and he proposes and she says no
and he is on a boat for five days in
alaska nonetheless within his her entire
extended family and they're br they're
broken up so he's like trying to hook up
with other girls on the boat he's like
trying to rebound he's staying together
now did they no
everywhere he goes it's just family her
family yeah and half of them don't even
know they're like hey i think you guys
are great like it's just like it was a
nightmare and then you have to put on
like the you have to flex for it and you
have to like put on the the illusion
like you're like don't tell grandma
don't tell grandparents
you have to keep up like it was just
like why would you propose i guess no
people always assume no one's ever gonna
say no right yeah which is why they
involve a diamond so that you that you
do say yes yes it really is an ambush i
mean they really don't set you up to be
able to make an educated choice i my
husband said he knew he loved me the day
he was willing to share his food with me
and that's pretty much the most romantic
thing anybody's ever said he's like i
knew when i was willing to like split
appetizers with you i was like ah i like
her she's she's the one and then when my
dad got sick my husband flew down to
um
to the hospital where my dad was and he
asked my dad and he was like you know
like we've been together a while at that
time and he was like you know i i was
gonna marry your daughter the first day
i met her
very sweet and he was like can i have
her hand in marriage i might as she goes
it's about time you fucking pussy
flatlined swear to god and jeff was like
yeah he's like of course welcome to our
family i fucking love you are there any
wedding traditions that as you're about
to the wedding that you feel like is not
uh like i'm very torn on the seating
chart on one hand i oh so i'm just doing
that now are you thinking like just
mix it up stir the pot a little bit my
thing is
anyone sit wherever you want
on one hand i want to be that person
like i was planning a wedding that ended
up not happening a couple years ago but
on the other hand i there's so many of
my friends that i want to meet and hang
out and that i think would be so cool to
know each other that i really want to
curate it but then i know as a
perfectionist i'll be walking around
being like emily why aren't you sitting
in your seat i want like i don't it
can't be attached to any results like
you have to be okay when your plan
totally falls apart
i have so like i have my my friends my
sorority friends from mississippi i my
friends when i live down in l.a i've got
my new york friends my atlanta friends
so i've got i'm ready to stir the
fucking pot okay so you have
intermediate times like teams situations
okay so you're on the white horse you're
on the right away yeah yeah you're
hitting gangs against each other
basically sure as fuck and i am getting
a high from it that is
what is the mentality when peop that's
like what why they stormed the capitol
people got together
but my friends like if you if you're you
can't put that many people with a lot in
common together but if you infiltrate my
friend group i'm the kind of person
where i'm like all my professional
friends know my best friends from
college know my friends from you know
that one time i blacked out in portland
like i like to intermix everybody i like
every and i gotta be honest with you the
fucking self-indulgence around this
wedding like i just finished the tour
and i've been doing this and it's i feel
like it's not just for you it's for
everyone else but that's what i'm saying
like i don't even give a shit we're
legally married we got legally married
during covid to me i just want to have
the celebration of all of my favorite
fucking people yeah and i'm just like i
want you guys i'm forcing fun i'm like
you're gonna come to italy you're gonna
eat pasta and black out with me and
we're gonna have so much fun i love that
because i when a friend of mine got
married i was in italy i was so annoyed
it was just like how much is this gonna
cost me like you know what how about
like you better stay together you know
it's like um and then i planned a trip
around it and i was like i'm so grateful
for this because i never would have gone
have you not done that no fucking guilt
asking people to come to italy because i
told you off air i said i invited you
know 200 people i'm thinking maybe you
know you can come or you doesn't make
the cut and who are there any people
that are invited that you're like uh
i had to um no i honestly kept it i kept
it tight because a lot of times
destination weddings only the weirdos
show up well you've got everyone coming
i will say there were a couple people
where i was like oh they're they're
never gonna say yes but everyone said
yes like post pandemic everyone has
fucking said yes cause they're like we
haven't been out of the house two years
we're fucking going to italy this is
gonna be a rager and everyone has said
yes so now i am responsible for
entertaining 200 people in italy and i'm
panicking about you you don't have to
entertain them just say look at my
stories yes i have highlights check my
highlights
no i mean like my wedding yes like
that's the responsibility do you have i
mean how much do you have to whenever i
go to a wedding i completely ignore the
bride me too i'm like that's a celebrity
i'm leaving her alone yeah i'm like i
don't want it like you'll let me know if
you need something because you know my
character like if you need someone to
but i'm like you're the best boy i'm
your guy if people aren't coming up to
me at my wedding being like you look
fucking thin and fabulous and we want to
know all your secrets i will i'll murder
everyone there how did you decide on a
dress it's getting because i'll tell you
how i decided on a dress i went wedding
dress shopping one day and it was the
most soul draining wanted to literally
it was so terrible because because when
you're bigger than a size like two right
you go in and i'm like at 12 14. they
would just like can you imagine what
this would look like and they come out
with these big clips they're like so we
could do this dress in your size and
bridal sizing is already fucked up so
say if you're like a size six yeah in
bridal sizing you're really like an 18.
it's just it's weird it's great how the
numbers go so if you go in there and
you're like i'm a 14. they're like well
we're gonna go out to the barn get a
couple things sew them together we're
gonna take uh our kkk
sheets to get sheets and we're gonna
make you awake
we're gonna just so the whole town is
gonna come together and bring their
cloak so we're gonna make you a drink
some
bounty washcloths and we gonna make you
a nice dress yeah so i said fuck it i
had one experience i was like so you
don't even have anything in this store
that i could even like slip over
size in america is 14 isn't it yeah also
the bridal industry is really fucked up
it is very fucked up so i've had a great
designer at a dallas and she is custom
making it and i'm going to tell you this
right now i gave her two things i said i
want to look like an italian hooker and
if i don't walk down the island somebody
yeah from jeff's family yells whore that
i will not be like giving off the vibe
that i want i want it
and then what shoes um figuring it out
because we don't want a shoe that will
break up the leg line and i've got no no
or break the ankle or break the angle
yeah
and then are you doing a honeymoon
you're going to other places in italy
yeah i want to talk about i love i want
to focus on your italian ancestry and
the ant what is the ancestral uh trauma
of italians
so it's so layered it's important i just
found out we found where my great great
grandfather is from in sicily so i'm
doing my a part of my honeymoon
i think sebastian has he's sicilian
because if you're sicilian you don't say
you're italian you're like there's the
difference between sicilian and italian
and what is that um it's just sicilians
are just wilder and they're like they're
on an island on their own right
right but so i am going to
go to the village where my family's from
but i also have a family that lives up
in venice and but my husband's family is
like very italian you know because
they're in new york that was the other
thing they didn't think that i could
actually be italian because i'm from
georgia it's like this whole thing so
we're going to this confusion and
everyone's gonna out italian each other
you know
like that's it so have you seen the
videos of how venice is flooding yeah it
was just there and it is it is literally
underwater i mean it is sinking yeah
november 2019 venice experienced its
worst flooding in over 50 years
affecting 75 percent of the city they
tried to make these giant balloon walls
and they have like like raised like if
you go in san marco square they have
like almost rafters look at that's what
they they put basically they're trying
to make a wall to stop
basically the water from coming in
because they have to put these like
walkways that are tendency
yeah the raptors and you have to walk
over you're walking on like a gymnastics
beam 100 through san marco square it's
bad is this going to sink in our
lifetime yeah for sure isn't florida
supposed to be underwater in like any
many years any minute
i mean it was like yeah it was the what
happened with katrina i mean that was
the first like guys coastal cities are
not a good idea not great and then sandy
in new york and everyone's like we're
back it's like dude you guys were so far
underwater that's why i won't buy
beachfront property i do have yeah it's
just i would rent yeah do a rental the
liability insurance alone is it's too
much but
venice being this far underwater is so
wild cause you'll like be going around
in the boats and you'll see
the water line that have been there
and it's day to day that's a wild thing
and i don't really understand how tides
work i don't understand truly how
flooding works it's like traffic like i
don't get how it works are we all going
the same place but when you're in venice
like one afternoon it'll be totally fine
and then the next day it's the they have
the rafters out and the balloons i mean
does this work
i
fuck if i know i went to school in
mississippi
i don't fucking know that guy seems
confident yeah i mean it's the fact that
they're like
it's just like a cartoon marvel idea
like let's just build walls like you
know yeah that um
stop it from flooding i mean it's just
like it's it is so weird to me to think
about when i'm in italy i'm always like
how is this thing still like is it
preserved is there a gay airplane there
are a lot of environmentalists and i
know it's a big part of like the real
venetians that live there like obviously
they want to preserve their city but i
think the rest of the world we've just
you know melted plastic into the ocean
so we're to blame right right but venice
is one of my absolute favorite places
and if you haven't been go it's magical
it's magical it is it's magical emily
and i went together yeah um it's a
it's magical in a way that it's like
enchanting and it makes it made me feel
like i was in like a disney movie
secretly deep down i am a maximalist
like this is my dream aesthetic the
podcast studio like and i love that
italian
um
is just more is more marble opulence
tassels we got tassels we've got gilded
lions i mean it never i've always got a
couple chains on you got new money i'm
very new money like yesterday just
cashed the check new money but if you
don't think that i've got a couple it
changes extra it's like you need to be
enjoying visual opulence when you look
up and that is why at my wedding it is
my wedding dress is feathered love it
like glitter it is fucking heavy it is
opulent the theme for my wedding is
house of gucci black tie yes i don't
care if you come to this wedding in a
banana hammock and a fucking bird on
your head you feel fabulous are you
showing out so good so do it that that
makes me really happy i think because i
think a lot of brides sometimes don't
want anyone to like no i love it i'm
like i challenge you how many
bridesmaids you come from sorority i'm
not doing any bridesmaids love it
because southern the girls i know that
are southern i haven't talked to them in
20 years they call me like we'd be my
bridesmaid i'm like i haven't yeah we're
not meeting you in 20 years you didn't
come to a single one of my fucking shows
joining the 42 people for the trip to
alfred angelo we're all getting our
peach colored satin
you know hooded dress we're not doing
that i'm having some friends in the
wedding i'm having my four best
girlfriends like take photos and i got
them dresses i'm like pick out whatever
you want from this website why you feel
fabulous no one's walking down the aisle
except me and my mom this is actually
very sweet my mom is wearing i'm getting
her custom tux right now because since
my dad passed and my mom and dad had a
wonderful relationship my mom is going
to wear a similar like my dad in their
wedding photos were almost like a
morning jacket so it's like you know
with the tails so she's getting a custom
touch with tails so she's gonna walk me
down the aisle in a tux and then put on
something fabulous after heaven yeah
yeah yeah my uh dear friend who uh
was married in italy her mom had passed
when she was younger and she walked down
the aisle holding like a rose and i was
like oh that's so cute like that's her
bouquet or whatever with her dad and
then her dad sat down and
i literally cried every day put the rose
in the seat it was just so
it was so fun cut out of my dad because
that's how sick i am my mom was like
heather this is great oh this is
hysterical and i'm like you're dressed
like my dad you know as he was at
y'all's wedding and then my wedding
planner was like please for the love of
god don't do a hologram don't do a voice
recording that's don't make other people
uncomfortable i was like this is fucking
hysterical like so let me work through
my trauma how i worked through it i lost
the love of my life who was my father
the greatest dad in the world and i'm
like let me if i want to fucking drag
his ass down the aisle
let me live my life it is so funny
got shut down taking a little break to
talk about my dogs
so uh you've heard me wax poetic you've
heard me use this podcast as a bully
pulpit
to talk about how most people feed their
dogs the wrong things dogs need to eat
what dogs would naturally eat in the
wild i have two dogs that are on heart
medications now um because their hearts
are broken from every time i leave oh
that's so sweet but also because i
stupidly fed them beans peas and lentils
because i thought it was healthy for
them because i was a big dum-dum but i'm
not a big dum-dum anymore thanks to dr
marty petz he essentially made this dog
food to combat the fact that most dog
food is trash most of it is just like
burnt nonsense or it's something that
would be healthy for a human but not
necessarily healthy for a dog so it's
called nature's blend once you feed
nature's blend to your dog they will
dive right in they will love every bite
my dogs mona frank and ludo love
nature's blend dr marty
pets.com
slash whitney that's d-r-marty
m-a-r-t-y-pets.com
whitney or text whitney 511 511 text
whitney to 5 11
5
11. and for a limited time you can save
50 off your first order your voice your
voice
is going on over here today i am so
sorry you guys also dr marty pets offers
a 100 90 day return on your first
purchase
text
w-h-i-t-n-e-y if you don't know how to
spell it by now to 511-511 or go to
doctormartypets.com whitney today and
save 50
off your first order what a bargain text
fees may apply they might you may
receive up to one additional text take
the win that's gonna put me over the
edge make your ex jealous make your guy
jealous text stop sorry he's a doctor to
opt out yeah you're being texted by a
doctor take the win mud water when i
think mud water i think emily in a pig
bog
but luckily
that was the best financial decision i
ever made
but mud water is a coffee alternative
with four adaptogenic mushrooms and
ayurvedic i've never known how to say
this but i've always wanted to ayurvedic
ayurvedic ayurvedic ayurvedic so here's
the deal coffee's a nightmare
as you can tell it stunted my growth
and it makes me dehydrated it gives me
headaches i've been looking for a coffee
substitute my entire life and vodka did
not work no
um and we all could smell it yeah that
was
that was a tough run yeah um and this is
called mud water it is whole 30 approved
100 usda organic non-gmo gluten-free
vegan and certified
sugar kosher that's amazing i do it with
almond milk or oat milk can i see that
look how cool this packaging is first of
all the first time i saw this was um i
was in i was shooting something in san
francisco and that's where all the cool
people are yeah and they had this all
over their desk and i was like i need to
have it look how cool this is chaga
lion's mane cordyceps cinnamon turmeric
himalayan salt only 20 calories
one tablespoon you just mix it in oh my
god i'm so obsessed with this stuff
how good is that that's yeah remember
remember that time i tried to do a
coffee substitute it was a big bag and
it was like dandelion powder yes i did
oh it was like eight years ago we were
shitting for days i remember there was
that other one like the raja's cup yeah
i i blocked that out i have tried to
find a coffee substitute for so long
finally have it thank you so much this
is very exciting this is such cool
packaging i'm just obsessed go to
m-u-d-w-t-r
whitney to support the show and use
whitney code for 15 off
back to our guest okay i want to know
okay
italian like what is ancestral tron
because i know a lot about the italians
that immigrated to the united states and
went into appalachia like coal mines
like west virginia italians yes you guys
came where so
boston so my mom's whole side of the
family is all from boston and then my
mom said i guess my grandfather was in
the mob because she said your
grandfather would set up businesses and
then charge people 40
you know to run the dry cleaners i'm
like that's extortion she was my mom
you know i was like um papa was was in
the mob she's like i guess that's
whatever you call it so
i've been doing a little ancestry.com i
haven't done the 23andme i know i'm
italian i know i'm scott's irish like
that is it it is me too
yeah that's fascinating and i just
talking about i've been thinking about
the mafia a lot lately because i do
think for all of the shit i talk about
crypto
yeah like invisible money like why did
anyone think this is a good idea i do
think that
uh that crypto and untraceable currency
will make it conducive for the mafia to
come back and be able to operate
uh
like how g's operate in silence like
lasagna
the
mafia is gonna be able to come back yeah
and it's gonna fade the homeless problem
like that's where they shine taking care
of the homeless putting them in the
concrete or whatever putting them in our
sidewalks
grinding them up and put you down i
would like a member of the mafia to
stand up and just let us know how you're
going to help the community dude we
literally had i mean it's everyone's
biggest complaint in l.a it's the
homeless problem homes every city every
city yeah on my exit it was a full
encampment
one day out of nowhere so
not not a
not a sleeping bag not a fanny pack not
a satchel not a loose cigarette not a
loose cigarette not one slap bracelet
left behind and what does the next door
say about it and now it's well the now
it's everyone's getting robbed in
brentwood
the chilean mafia picks up homeless
people gives him a bmx and a tommy
bahama shirt and they go out and scout
and rob people wait a minute the chilean
mob chilean
wildly specific and that's what that's
there's a chilean mob issue in calabasas
who the fuck knew me wow yes the wizard
whitney the whistleblower on the chilean
mind i'm just saying we gotta get stay
focused everyone on what really counts
but but the mafia has not been able to
operate uh and the mafia
exists to fill in the blanks where the
government won't right like i was
watching this documentary about um in
the 80s they're basically cleaning up
new york and on the subways like you
know they were stepping in and doing the
things that police wouldn't do maybe
there's like a next generation of mafia
my sorority sisters we've done a lot of
charity work and sorties are very
similar to like moms yeah so i'm just
saying
you know everyone wants to shit on
people who enjoy their sorority well you
fuck you i'm just helping the people of
oxford mississippi left and right okay
we're our own mob we have great days to
throw fucking fantastic parties you're
welcome i don't want to uh uh
you to get in trouble but is there any
like when you go into sorority do you
just like everyone no of course not
there were some weirdos in my pledge
class yeah and so how do you get kicked
out um people have to vote you off the
island no no there's no voting i mean
listen you have if you're you know
blowing 55 people in public i mean
actually we probably kept you down but
you'd probably win a trophy usually was
grades you would get on probation you
were like listen if you're like also
okay i know i'm gonna get so much shit
for this but it was like a little checks
and balances like we had people in the
story to be like hey are you drinking
too much and you haven't gone to any of
your classes you're about to get kicked
out of college so like you had to keep a
specific gpa
in the sorority that was a big thing and
the gpa like you had to at least have a
3.0 yeah to like stay in so that was
kind of nice it was like a chance to
have like a big sister you know here's
my deal i just don't want someone my age
to be my boss
okay then yes i was i was a a boss lady
i was in charge of shit i would just i i
have trouble like i can hardly do like
exercise classes because i'm like why
are you yelling you can't talk to me
like that like i just we're both adults
like i just why when we walk in this
room you're allowed to yell at me and as
soon as we walk out that's a crime i
will say i went into sororities not
knowing anything but like if you go to
school mississippi like that's what you
do i i thought it was gonna be that
whole scene from like a movie where they
like line you up and they're like you're
fat you need to fix this by the way i
was traumatized by parker posing in days
you infused exactly it was not that i
showed up they're like honey we got you
crystals and gifts and like it was just
these sweet southern women giving me a
ton of fucking swag and then we went
drinking and like smoked eggs and had a
good time it was great i i very pr the
older i get the more pro team sports i
am and the more pro i am greek life yeah
listen i have a adult sorority right now
it's called pi kappa pasta and it's a
bunch of my girlfriends
and we're all in our mid thirties don't
have kids yeah i e yeah p.i like yeah
like
like you could add pie into it
yes you could sorry pie cappa pasta
because our first trip was to italy so
that's our thing we like to eat right so
we're a group of like 20 women and we
just call ourselves like an older
sorority and anybody can join i think
the next trip we're gonna do we're just
gonna fucking run out of cruise ship
invite whoever wants and there's we
should run the kesha cruise ship oh fuck
yeah
does a cruise that's like just
ridiculous and pitbull does a cruise and
i'm people's number one fan i love
pitbull it's not true it's literally
true i love pitbull i used to have
really i used to dress like him like
full drag like i love pitbull
it's wild how how accurate i can look
like pitbull
i'll show you and you're gonna go uh
well i'll give it to you so you can put
it up it's literally like when you see
me as people you're gonna go that's
pitbull and
and we have the same we're at the same
agency but he is not my agent's like i
can't get him to go like that
i i open my show at the farewell tour i
open my show with a video as me as
pitbull like hyping up the crowd so and
everybody knows like that's me but it's
pitbull i love him if you haven't been
to a pitbull concert let me tell you
this right now yeah it will bring you i
can already tell you don't want to join
me for a pitbull concert i'll i will
take you and it'll be the most joyful
night of your life i'm with you on this
pitbull knows the assignment he knows
when pitbull's making
one of the funniest moments i've ever
had in my life and i really want to put
it in the show i was i threw a
bachelorette party for a girlfriend of
mine and it was like kind of small like
uh it was like eight people like around
the couch i got like a mentalist like it
was like cool it wasn't like but one
girl was getting like shit-faced
yeah like clearly like had a problem
everyone else was like kind of sipping
cows and popping she was like doing
shots alone like that so and she would
get up into the mentalist like oh you
can read my mind oh yeah what am i
thinking right like she was like so
embarrassing like it was like very bad
like actually kind of like assaulting
like afterwards we were like how what do
you mean yeah
like maybe there's an intervention to be
had or whatever because she was just
fucking drinking fireball like just
drinking firewall sounds and legit she
like goes
she go in the plastic bottle like
they're like
she has a problem
if you're gonna like no glass bottles
for fireball they know this is gonna end
up being projectile thrown out of human
yeah and uh it got really quiet and a
girlfriend of mine just went
fireball
and anytime something's weird we say
like pitbulls like that's the song i
come out fireball
you can't you can't be in a bad mood
when you hear it you can't i went to a
pitbull conference
mr worldwide
dolly good for you i went to a concert
my girlfriend bought us tickets she's
like let's get high go to football
concert like fuck it that's my best
friend from kindergarten we went we had
never had so much fun and even if you
don't know like you don't you just hear
pitbull in top 40. yeah you go to a
concert you're like i know every fucking
song
not only that every it's every song is
your the song you would walk to the
dance floor for if you heard it
somewhere
like that was gonna be late about a week
ago and you're like oh yes but i got
just enough yes i never had so much fun
so then i started doing an impression of
him and then i just became obsessed with
him and i actively i thought about
getting tickets for the pitbull cruise
and dressing up as him because when i
dress and drag his pitbull it is wild
you literally are like
the same face or something and i look
very strong in a bald cap and i thought
about going on the cruise and like doing
meet and greets after dark party that
looks upsetting
like a hilarious giant dick
oh yeah like totally like hilarious
white jeans no but it's i think it's
like a big thing on the internet i'm
just going to put this out there just
because it's a public platform if by the
time this airs if anybody is able to
wrangle people to perform at my wedding
i will suck your dick you know what i
mean
that is like i keep thinking that maybe
my husband's gonna pull it off but i
know he's not i don't know if he's gonna
do private gigs for you he's got um uh
he's got
vodka now but also
i don't i do think you could get this if
nothing else we can remix the idea with
your dad with pitbull
because he does have cardboard cutouts
of himself okay
can you i need this i need that
information
so cardboard cut out a pitfall at your
wedding and i'll just say thank you for
to my dad for being here that was like
mr worldwide my real dad
my real father well the funny thing is
my parents didn't meet him man he was
filled the hole
that was removed when he crossed this is
god this is all working out this is
great yeah that's all i love this i love
you know i just like le to laugh live
laugh love live laugh
what if they should put that on a pillow
they really should be a big business uh
before i let you leave i do have to ask
when people are in happy relationships
what give advice because i think most of
the time single people take advice from
single people which is dumb dumb silly
goose uh i always say
only ask your happily friends are in a
good relationship what is
the advice you would give
uh
in terms of like for example like
sometimes you just have to eat a dick
that's like the best advice i know you
absolutely have to eat a dude you're
right you're correct yeah they're wrong
and you just have to eat a dick and go
you know what i'm so i'm sorry i wasn't
meaning it that way my mom says the day
you quit blowing them is the day they
leave you so i would say do i like
giving blow jobs no i don't do i do i'm
sorry i didn't mean it no i actually
meant you you have to do it yeah no well
in that case i'll be single forever
because i have a bad back but i like as
in
you have to choose your battles and if
you win we both lose so i can win this
yes but then if i do
you're gonna be resentful and
embarrassed yeah uh i'm gonna
have lost respect for you i'm just doing
this for ego or whatever you know you
know what
i'm sorry you feel that way because
feelings aren't facts so if you hurt
someone and they're you well i didn't
mean to but that was my intention
intention and impact impact is all that
matters just focus on the impact
and like that's been good advice for me
because i'm like a justice where i'm
like let's fucking argue this out and
i'll show you how right i am right
because i don't want someone to think i
was stupid or dishonest so i feel the
need to be right but that's there's no
point i'm married to the most stubborn
man on the planet and i'll tell you this
right now i am the first person to go
you know what agree to disagree i'm
sorry and i walk away it is not worth it
i'm him i'm i'm him i mean he will fight
you to the neander bike now this is why
you know whatever and i'm like okay jeff
you win i literally say you win and i
walk away and now that we solved that
argument let's now talk about your tone
during the argument because now that's a
whole step i'm all about tone i am all
about uh your eyes better stay looking
at me they better not go back in your
head one time jeff and i i mean we
really do he we do have a great
relationship and i love him but i mean
marriage is hard you do have to work on
it but how get like how how what does
everyone say because there are some days
you were looking at this person i'm like
i'm gonna fucking murder him yeah you
know what i mean if you my husband tapes
his mouth shut at night because he read
some book called breathe about how we're
not using our noses correct so right
like he dicks me down and then he puts
tape on his mouth and i'm looking at him
just like and i go jeff did you do
anything on the ch like anything on the
checklist that i need you to do today no
get to tomorrow takes his mouth rolls
over and i'm like this is it like this
is the dairy that are just gonna snap
the neck you know what i mean like that
shit you have to still love that person
i i we've gotten to a place cause like
i'm on the road obviously working and
like i've had a moment in my career and
i say i don't want to resent you
there are certain things that i think
also
howard stern and bezdard taught me this
they have separate bathrooms and they've
never seen each other pee or poop or
fart well that's 20 years that's insane
it works for them that it does yeah
you have to know what you need there's a
couple things like i my dude is younger
than me
eight years younger than me and before
bed he does put in a retainer
yeah and
i'm fine with it but can you just do it
without me i don't need to see it that
happens like you can do it without me
seeing it do you want to do news around
each other once it's in your mouth don't
speak okay so also you fall asleep
marriage my number one advice is you
just need to be prepared that when
you're married specifically i'd say
maybe a straight woman to a straight
male you will know when your partner has
diarrhea every day i know jeff's i don't
want to know but every day is like oh
babe this is good or it's like you know
taxi from the golf course like oh i was
coming around nine and uh something
happened i'm like i don't need to know
please don't please don't please please
don't every day like we had dinner the
other day was like okay we gotta get out
of here i gotta take a dump
and i stopped and i go
like it's funny but now like i just
enjoyed this really great meal and now i
gotta rush home because you have
explosives
shitting it out can you get on your body
a little longer we just paid for it yes
i would draw a boundary on that
but we laugh we giggle it's hilarious
it's hilarious but there are days where
i'm like if i'm gonna have sex with you
later please i don't i have diarrhea too
i had celery juice this morning but
don't tell me where it's like it's it's
picking your moments it's like alex is
younger than me and
it's things that are so funny are so
funny but sometimes it's just a tonnage
so making fun of me being older is like
like sometimes it's the funniest thing
ever most of the time but every now and
then it hits me sideways you never know
when the thing you've been cool with for
so long is gonna just hit you sideways i
have one bit of advice for single people
though and tell me if you agree with
this love this okay my one bit of advice
is if the relationship is hard when you
start dating
you're out it will never change it will
never change if it is if you if you're
clicking and and it's it's effortless i
mean you still obviously have to put an
effort but if you if it is hard and
confusing and you don't really know how
that person feels about you at the
beginning it's not going to get better
it this is my best advice i ever got you
should be everything in a relationship
it is okay to be obsessive it's okay to
be jealous it's okay to be scared the
one thing you should never be is
confused i absolutely agree that is the
only like all the other stuff is normal
i'm jealous i'm scared i'm worried i'm
afraid of abandoned man he is how you
feel about me period period and if you
if you are okay with the vagueness like
the person you care about you don't want
them to will have to wonder yeah either
you like me or you don't you don't have
to be in love with me right this second
i don't want to be someone on the back
burner while you're just working it out
with other people 100 agree yeah i think
it's just my thing is like call me when
this can be yeah
on the
this will never work right but let's
regroup in six months if you're out of
that mess let's try again but like yeah
i think that the way it starts is the
way it continues yeah because it's only
going to get harder and you're setting a
precedent that that's something you'll
tolerate and that's something you're
okay with and then it just becomes like
a habit you're casting a certain role
and then it's just like no you have to
set the standard up front what do i
expect what do i want yeah and then and
listen then they'll show their true
colors
we do everything backwards i feel like
with this we we
when you first meet someone you want to
put your quote best foot forward but
you're kind of just pretending to be
someone else right you know for the
first couple months and then you sort of
let your guard down stop wearing makeup
start to be yourself and
and then it's like well he doesn't
accept me for who i am it's like well
you also lied
it was all you know what i mean it's
just sort of like i feel like we should
be as honest and direct as possible for
the first three four months and then
when the person is then you start
putting on the best version of yourself
you know what i mean because now this is
the person like now i'm gonna show you
what i look like if i do put on
concealer
let's go to a fancy dinner it's like
you're not a shallow piece of shit so
now you're going to get me at my best
yes so now you're going to get me
dazzling you in like you know cute
lingerie but i think also with like
paying for i was i always thought that
for paying for meals i'm like what if
the first four days you just split it
and then once you're together
uh you he can start paying for you you
guys can start doing that because guys
uh girls do like if you spent money on
someone you're
there's a different not even like sex
and being expected to sleep with them or
something there's just this like
i don't want you to be out of pocket on
me
because i don't want you to measure how
cool i am based on how much you spent
you know i'd rather it just be
no i want you showing up to the first
date in a stretch limousine being like
let's go eat caviar because you deserve
it bitch those titties are fire see i
don't know i want to feel fire
balls
no no i want to be interested
yeah i just feel like sometimes i'm like
i don't want the pressure of you having
spent a hundred bucks because i want to
reserve the right to be kind of boring
at dinner or like you can still be
boring you know what i mean no i i hear
you i hear you on that i mean uh-huh
yeah or i just think there's a lot of
guys they don't give a girl a third
chance because they're like oh i spent
100 bucks already and it did you know
it's like well it takes time to get to
know somebody i i think don't go too
expensive too fast unless you have the
money
okay i hear you and when you have 200
bucks and you spend 100 on a date i
don't want to be that girl because then
you're going to resent me jeff and i's
first date was we went um ice skating at
bryant park you know what i mean a 15
dollar date it was he's been trying to
murder you for a year
now you're going to eat on a cliff in
italy i mean he just cannot yeah so you
know he's like slicing around the ice
and of course i'm from atlanta i'm like
baby giraffe legs but we were on our
date and i got nervous again i have to
keep the conversation going so i go
who's your celebrity crush we're like 22
at the time and he's like um
eva longoria mila kunis and i literally
stopped and i go you couldn't say
fucking jessica simpson or like a
champion
like what the fuck you took no i mean
you asked me what did you expect from
like oh my god so i know i'm not your
type so i'm not your type size date in
tears thinking
yeah and he was like i had a great time
i'll call you tomorrow and i just left
he probably thinks they're both italian
though exactly i left it in tears it's
not that he was mean to you he's just
racist
he can't tell the difference between
hispanic latina i'm like you said
anybody with blonde hair and big tits
and he was like oh you were asking me
like it was just also men are just you
know what i mean yeah i know they don't
know
and alex he does some genius things men
that are listening there's some genius
things that my guy does which is when i
do ask something like that like hey like
if we broke up he'll be the first and he
would just be like this feels like a
trick yeah he will just put it he was
just like there's let me let me have a
second to just play this out yeah i'm
not letting you do this yeah uh and then
he'll say if i um
want to like buy something or want to
wear a certain thing i'll be like do you
like this he says if you like it i love
it
oh if you like it i love it okay and
it's this weird
i don't know why it calms me down so
much well he knows he knows how to make
you feel self-assured and i will say
another great piece of advice is they
should celebrate you in a relationship
like when you're in the relationship if
you're not celebrating each other what
are we doing yeah
and yes and it's like for example when
he passes boards he's a veterinarian it
was like we're gonna go to dinner
and we're gonna in the south you go to
you commemorate an occasion yes and
there's this thing now we're just like
sure about you
exactly we're in we're getting the
cottage cheese with the pineapple
absolutely we're getting uh also we're
putting chocolate on oreos like but just
going this dinner is specifically to
celebrate your thing and i just even
mean like in the relationship like there
shouldn't be jealousy like it's wild to
me sometimes when spouses get jealous of
each other because of like professional
wins a relationship win or something i'm
like that doesn't make sense to me
that's bad but that's bad i do think
it's
not as long as your motives are clear
and you know that it's your abandonment
shit or just yeah like getting jealous
of
um
your ex's your your person's exes and
stuff i think there's a certain element
of that that's like healthy and normal
yeah you know oh no get getting of x's i
mean jeff's ex showed up to a borrow in
time and i literally i'm 25 feet taller
than her and i almost body checked her
and i said listen bitch
there's a new sheriff in town yeah yeah
yeah
and she was shit herself and i was like
walk away bitch
but there's like fireballs
the irony is i should love you because
you loved this person that i we both
loved the same person so we should on
some level like the fact that you love
the person i love you must be pretty
cool no i didn't murder any of jeff
jeff's exes like if a chick came out of
the woodwork no i'd be like what's your
name tamra that's fucking brawl no
no jeff has no love before me no love
after me and i i mean i tell him all the
time i'm like if god forbid you get hit
by a bus tomorrow like
i will date again and you're allowed to
date again as well but just know that
you know if that happens to me
and i will i will fuck you up the rest
of your life
and i'm not jealous at all but i i will
fuck up everyone
but jeff is so not jealous there are
days he's so secure in himself and i
mean obviously as an entertainer you get
a lot of weird you know i can yeah yeah
but like we've been at a bar before and
somebody's been like damn this your girl
like whatever like shaking his hand like
fuck yeah and all this and jeff just
sits back and beans he at no point is
ever like man you love that back he's
never but to the point where i hold him
sometimes it talks away but um i was at
the mall today you know or whatever and
somebody cat called me and asked me for
my number and he was like as they should
ask you for your number because that's
it i'm like are you not jealous because
i was raped today yeah jeff would he's
just so chill and i don't know if like
secretly maybe he gets jealous but he's
he's he's always just like yeah you're a
babe and i'm like thank you
i do think in a relationship you have to
be a fan of the other person yeah my
thing is you i have to look up to the
person i'm with like i have to actually
look up to them if i don't call you for
advice when i'm in a jam it's never
gonna work yeah it's a little thing that
i've noticed about myself whereas if i'm
not asking someone for advice should i
take this job or that i don't think
you're smart enough and if i start
calling my other friends then it's just
why there's gonna be a wedge yeah you
have to be like that to me like and he
is when i he's my google he's he can do
fucking anything like i need that i need
someone i'm kind of in awe of and that's
the thing dude jeff and i have been
together forever but he's the only one
he can look at me and be like
sit down you're being a crazy fucking
bitch yeah and i respect it and i go you
are right yes sir i will slow down and
mine my mind
enough to when they tell you like he uh
he said to me one time there was like a
behavior that was not great during the
pandemic i was taking edibles when i had
coveted and then it was like the
pandemic it was like you've taken out
about eight a week later you're taking
one in four then it's bleeding into like
noon and uh uh and it was very unclear
because i had like long covered but then
it was kind of clear when that
overlapped with just like taking edibles
all day and he was like um never
micromanaged never judgey he just said
like
this is
getting less cute oh i love that and
then you know yeah yeah i'm gonna lock
it up and i was like that is you said it
in the perfect way that's exactly how i
need to hear it because you know
everyone's on drugs right now everyone's
doing microdosing lsd but not that i'm
against it i really want to
uh reap whatever benefits from ayahuasca
i have no desire
but a lot of people are doing micro
dosing yes and i'm always looking right
and so um yeah i think i'm a little bit
addicted to healing whereas i'm like i'm
kind of happy now i might not have to do
that but i have this thing in the back
of my head that's like you know you come
from a family that mental health was
never
a thing and after my dad died i had so
much grief i was just trying to do
anything and i'm still at a point i
haven't you know i i don't think i'll
ever get over my dad
he just it breaks your heart in a way
that's like yeah i'm always like sad
ultimately like i'll have a great time
at a party everyone will leave and i'll
just like my dad's still dead you know
so i was a story of my life it always
hits me at costco you know father's day
is coming out by the way it is coming up
and some bitch texted me this past
sunday and goes i'm thinking of you and
i said what do you mean she's like
today's father's day and i'm like it's
not for two more weeks claire see i have
a bunch of friends that are a dead dad's
club and we text each other going hey
just a heads up like yeah i turn off
instagram for the three days before and
two days after because it's all like
milk it i'm like my dad's dead
um okay yes there's so much to cover
next time we'll get into the grief stuff
i know you have to catch a flight
because um uh it when we talk about
grief in a way with like levity and it
really helps a lot of people because um
you know but the big advice i give is
don't make any of your passwords your
dog's names your cat's names your dad or
your mom's names because when something
bad happens and one of them cross over
all of a sudden you're gonna need to get
in your computer your shit and it's all
gonna be your dad's name your mom's name
your dad's birthday like just don't make
any
major things like that
because when i went to the through the
grieving process i realized it was all
my dad's name it was all that you know
and then in the calendar father's day
comes up like there's just so much stuff
that you don't realize
uh
is en embedded in your life and then
you have a situation like that
i would just say this the one thing this
is so fucked up
i had to go on my dad's computer right
after like find some like tax papers or
whatever and i found i was going through
his thing and i found his porn
and i don't know why this sounds so
fucked up i've never said this out loud
but it was such like normal healthy porn
and it was like a beautiful like
interracial couple and i was like
progressive dad like i remember thinking
i saw his porn and i clicked on it i was
like i don't know why that made me feel
like he was such a good man like you
know when you're going through laptop
you think you might find something shady
like oh maybe not you know it was just
this beautiful moment where i was like
my dad was a great guy it was just like
a beautiful normal thing it wasn't like
you know bukkake or some shit i was like
my dad was honestly the fucking best he
was like a consensual missionary
interracial oh yeah it seemed very
romantic i was just so proud and i
haven't even told my sister this but i
was like i when i had to go through
dad's computer i was like wow i really i
just got a good picture of your mom
taped to the screens oh
no he did have photos of this one
weather woman who was a redhead and my
mom used to always joke but he's like
i'm into redheads he loved this one
weather woman
and my mom was like the photos are on it
was like nice interracial born and then
this one red-headed weather woman that
looked just like my mom he's a fucking
stand-up guy kyle mcmahon you were the
best gosh that's incredible that's good
that's good so if your parent does die
definitely if you find any of their porn
that will be the judgment of who they
were as a person okay either legacy no
truly that is their legacy i always end
these awkwardly i want to talk to you
forever
um uh but okay this is your podcast yep
absolutely not what a great title thank
you god damn and you put out what days
of the week uh wednesday we have an
absolutely not line you can call in with
any absolutely not so we we go through
it it might say we it's just me and then
your tour is wrapping up yeah just right
with the tour going to shoot a special
in august yeah that's where um figuring
that out somewhere in the south okay but
i'm doing it on my own so let's see i
just did that hold on whitney i have to
tell you this one thing though i totally
forgot about this i'm so embarrassed by
this i used to work at soul cycle in
west hollywood and i used to wait on you
all the time and i used to put my
business card in your bags when you'd
buy like a sweatshirt and weho and i
used to put it in your bag and i'd like
write a note like you ever need an
assistant if you ever need an opener i'd
love to do it and you never got me
i don't maybe you they were buying you
were buying gifts for other people and
then so like all your friends have my
business cards but i um used to give you
a business card a week two weeks to be
fair whitney would never have gone
through a bag like you would have never
you would have why do you think those
were gifts for my friends i don't know
there's always candles it was always the
same
lemon john
the john adler grapefruit candles best
candle on the planet it's so fucked up i
would walk into soul cycle buy a candle
and leave yes and i would it's basically
a candle store to me and actually i
think i put the business card in the
candle box so that's probably why you
never saw it because it was probably you
just like whipped out the candle and did
it but are you still available
i know this probably isn't the direction
your career is going my buddy ray was
like if you're going to see whitney
today make sure you remind her how you
used to beg her for a job at soul cycle
and now here we are i think that
dialogue is so
distracted by how uh
um
pounded my pussy had just gotten
because it's too much poundage
they need to make different seats i
agree and i also i can't believe i
didn't bring that up earlier because
that is one of the classes where i'm
like why are you yelling at me yeah my
pussy is being physically i'm being
female circumcised my lips like
going around the bike like how dare you
yeah so that
and then i was just waiting patiently
i'm like she's going to come out and
she's going to get a great free candle
and then i'm going to slide by this to
print business card that my mom made for
me online and shipped into my apartment
this was 10 years ago and here we are
you hear me begging you to be on the
podcast and that's why kids so can we
argue write shit down that me rejecting
you
or ignoring you completely was the best
thing that ever happened to you
absolutely
because if i had hired you you'd killed
myself
and that's how that worked out so i
actually just came here today to say
thank you whitney come on thank you
thank you for saying no
to a gal like me from georgia thank you
for uh not sharing that half the time my
credit card didn't go through
that
at least once a week i definitely went i
went a lot for a while yeah
yeah and then i i worked out all the
time i was in the best shape of my life
and victoria beckham came in when danger
goes do you like do this workout and i
was like
twice a day uh-huh
that's a whole nother thing we'll get
into that in another episode but here we
are i'll make it thanks for having me
i am obsessed with you thank you please
come back a million times and maybe we
can do another version with someone else
like let's just keep let's keep i love
you yeah i love you too i ever i mean
everyone does hey i'll do a test very
highly
thank you i just need all my shows to
get picked up because they keep not
getting so please pick up my phone
that's how it is how it is and then when
the one goes that you want you'll be
like thank god that one didn't go where
i you know
played the transgender hooker that
wouldn't have hold up held up well
that's awesome i'm glad we just did my
family sitcom about my italian family
they actually rejected the
the show about my family they're like we
know your dad's dead but can he not be
in this other version so we're reworking
oh yeah that would be mentally healthy
for me like can he just not be dead and
i go okay sure let me go back to the
drawing board wait by the way i asked
that every day too
every day i honestly i would love for
him to be this is so weird i i i'm turns
out i'm a studio executive i want my dad
to be alive also yes this is what's like
around the scenes crazy
yeah i want to not be a walking shell of
a person too exactly thank you so much
thank you so much for that it was just
me i thought everyone wanted my dad to
be dead it was just me
he watches interracial porn
that is so funny yeah all right well
let's talk about that okay okay i'm
jumping on a zoom don't be jealous um i
love you guys don't write elephants
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]